bonjour alexis je remercie beaucoup
d'être avec nous en ce lundi de pâques
dans la matinale de rtl france alors ce
week-end on appris justement la
participation potentielle de certains
nombres du gouvernement à des dîners
privés
c'étaient les premiers mots en tout cas
de l'un des organisateurs qu'en est il
exactement
oui alors vous venez de le rappeler puis
art en chalencon 7 collectionneurs
propriétaire du palais d'hygiène cette
propriété au coeur de paris organise des
déjeuners des dîners privés chez lui
avec un chef étoilé où il convient bien
deschamps célèbres ou non et il s'est
vanté devant les caméras d'une chaîne
concurrente avoir même dîné avec
certains ministres à la pallice c'était
des ministres en exercice d'anciens
ministres si c'était dans le cadre de
ses soirées etc
et puis hier soir on l'avocat de ce
monsieur dit que finalement c'était une
blague il était là pour rigoler mais en
aucun cas un ministre n'aurait bien
entendu bravé le couvre-feu pour faire
un dîner interdit alors non justement et
c'est là où c'est intéressant
rien dans la loi n'interdit ces dîners
privés finalement vous pouvez tout à
fait recevoir chez vous plus de six
personnes à table vous pouvez aussi
sortir papier mamie du balcon faire ce
que vous voulez parce que la loi nous
autorise vous êtes chez vous à faire ce
que vous voulez et y compris ses dîners
nombreux assis à table sans gestes
barrière avec un chef et c'est heureux
parce que je crois que si les policiers
débarquer chez vous pouvoir vérifier que
vous aviez votre masque que vous
respectez cette barrière les français
seraient pas tout à fait d'accord avec
ce genre de gestion sanitaire
donc ils utilisent un trou du droit qui
lui permet d'organiser ces dîners a
lancé hautement critiquable bien entendu
puisque au delà du prix du faste de ces
dîners il ya le risque que sanitaire
puisque les masses qui sont interdits
que les gestes barrière n'y sont pas
respectées et qu'il s'en vante sur les
réseaux sociaux
pierre jean salençon a mis à peu près
tout est public sur ces dîners vous
pouviez jusqu'à hier réservé pour
participer à un dîner de ce club depuis
les sites ont été supprimés par les
administrateurs et vous ne pouvez plus
réservé c'est malheureux mais voilà ce
qu'il en est évidemment ça pose question
sur ce genre de pratiques est sans doute
n'est-il pas le seul
vérifiez normands puisque ces dîners
sont payants donc peut-être y at-il un
flou juridique mais comme il y à une
transaction commerciale
on va vérifier tout ça gérald darmanin
en tout cas a demandé l'ouverture d'une
enquête pensez vous que la transparence
va être fait
oulala alors oui on peut on peut espérer
parce que là le gouvernement marche sur
des oeufs et la colère gronde parce
qu'on sent bien qu'il y a des privilèges
comme en 1789 à peu près donc
ça commence un peu à être fébrile en
haut là où il ya les privilèges et on
espère oui bien sûr qu'il y aura une
enquête jiménez le procureur de paris va
se chercher à savoir qui on est et ces
gens qui ont payé pour dîner comme vous
le dites il ya transaction donc ce n'est
pas un dîner privé
c'est effectivement un restaurant
clandestins on pourrait rentrer sous le
coup de la loi
alors est ce que monsieur challans on va
aller en garde à vue comme les
organisateurs d'apéros le long des quais
de saône
est ce que les participants vous
recevoir des amendes voire plus sains
comme ces malheureux qui faisait griller
des saucisses sur un barbecue ce
week-end
arrêté par la maréchaussée ça reste à
voir mais il ya eu un précédent c'était
un magistrat je crois qu'ils avaient été
pris la main dans le sac dans un
restaurant clandestins en janvier ou
février bien les poursuites ont été tout
simplement interrompue lâcher donc on se
rend bien compte qu'il ya une justice à
deux vitesses qui lie à bien des
privilégiés qui finalement s'en fichent
totalement du coc vide qui reste harvey
joueuses de classe puisque si vous
voulez vous consommé une bière sur la
voie publique 735 euros damende voilà
c'est dans l'autre sens alors que si
vous voulez payer pour aller manger chez
un ami étoiles et il n'y a pas de
problème visiblement jusqu'à présent
donc le risque aujourd'hui c'est
évidemment la volatilité de l'opinion
publique le fait aussi que ça va ça ne
peut pas durer
ce deux poids deux mesures et les
mesures sanitaires ne peuvent être
acceptée que si elles sont respectées
par tous sinon on se rend bien compte
que c'est une fumisterie
ouais effectivement alexis est ce que
c'est vrai qu'on demande toujours plus
d'efforts aux français quand il ya un
écart il ya une sanction alors est ce
qu'une telle nouvelle peut mettre à mal
finalement la politique du gouvernement
oui alors rien que cette nouvelle le
fait que le ministre de l'intérieur
n'ait pris aucune action alors même que
bercy par exemple accès aux réseaux
sociaux pour aller voir si il ya des
fraudeurs fiscaux qui n'utilisent
l'argent
de l'état pour faire autre chose que
chercher un emploi par exemple là rien
n'a été fait alors que tout était sur la
place publique donc ça pose la question
de la volonté de l'intérêt du
gouvernement on apprend aussi que
certains journalistes des chaînes d'info
en continu ont organisé des conférences
avec ce collectionneur
donc la question c'est l'arbre qui cache
la forêt c'est combien de pierre jean
salençon qui organise ce genre de
soirées privées pour des amis fortunés
qui finalement se fiche totalement du
virus puisque on va chez des amis on
revient et tout ça sans respecter le
couvre-feu c'était le cas du regretté
olivier dassault qui est mort dans un
accident d'hélicoptère en rentrant chez
des amis de normandie voilà un peu là la
vie des des très riches
au delà de toutes les gestes barrière de
toutes les mesures sanitaires comme si
le virus ne devait exister que pour les
plus pauvres
et ça ça ne peut pas durer et puis le
problème de l' exemplarité corps marlène
schiappa dit que si jamais il était fait
état que des ministres avaient participé
à ces dîners il devrait alors payer une
amende comme n'importe quel citoyen non
il faut aller beaucoup plus loin elle
s'est ensuite reprise sur twitter entend
bien sûr il devrait démissionner et
payer l'amendé mais on voit bien qu'en
france on a un petit problème quant à
l'exemplarité des élites et et des
ministres de généralement c'est on fait
ce qu'on veut tant qu'on n'est pas pris
et puis le moment on est pris alors on
tombe de très haut
rappelez vous la faire cahuzac et
d'autres affaires comme celle-ci
sauf que là en pleine crise sanitaire
alors que chaque jour chaque semaine le
président de la république demande
davantage d'efforts aux soignants aux
français à tous voir que certains
français privilégiés s'en fiche et
vivent une vie d'avant ça commence à
bien faire et je crois que là c'est la
dernière limite finalement pour que la
désobéissance deviennent mainstream les
français se sont montrés très
responsable et très patient en tout cas
avec ces mesures de privation de liberté
pensez vous que cette patience puisse
donc avoir des limites finalement
évidemment oui et d'ailleurs c'est à
cela qu'on voit la fébrilité du
gouvernement des porte parole et puis du
parti de la majorité présidentielle qui
a immédiatement riposté surtout réseaux
sociaux en dise non mais attendez ce
monsieur chalencon il est proche de la
fachosphère il fait n'importe quoi
monsieur chalencon se vantait d'être
l'ami de brigitte macron par exemple
donc c'est beaucoup plus compliqué et on
voit
bien que la wii il ya un problème un
problème de classe un problème aussi
d'hypocrisie totale entre la l'inanité
des mesures qu'on demande aux français
la violence aussi qui leur est faite
avec ces pv à 18 heures à 19 heures si
vous êtes pris dans les bouchons et dire
vous payer quand même ces pv pour
consommation d'alcool sur la voie
publique ça n'a aucun sens
les français le savent bien et pourtant
oui patiemment ils sont contraints par
la bande à obéir à des mesures ubuesque
que totalement abracadabrantesque quand
certains ceux là mêmes qui font la leçon
sur les plateaux de télévision ailleurs
et bien s'en fichent totalement et je
crois que là c'est la dernière limite
finalement pour que la cedh le
séparatisme un réel existe de cette
façon là soient vus et l'hypocrisie
tombe et plus rien de fonctionne des
mesures de coercition parce que le c'est
très simple de citer dans le micro
trottoir que vous avez montré sait si
elles le font pourquoi pas moi alors ça
suffit bien moi j'ai le droit de vivre
comme tout le monde comme ceux qui
vivent sans le virus pourquoi pas moi et
la cfi c'en est fini de la politique
sanitaire coercitives qui est encore une
fois je le répète à une politique
autoritaire de contrôle des populations
et non pas une politique sanitaire de
moyens donnés aux soignants c'est tout
le problème
merci beaucoup alexis alexis poulenc on
retrouve tous les lundis matin dans les
vidéos de la matinale un édito à revoir
en attendant sur les réseaux sociaux